[Musique]
le challenge des créateurs fête ses 20
ans la présentation de cette nouvelle
édition s'est tenue en présence du
département et des partenaires du réseau
point chance le challenge valorise
l'insertion par la création d'entreprise
est l'une des solutions de la station
professionnel et c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui les jeunes ils ont envie de
créer leur propre entreprise verte
propre emploi depuis la première édition
en 1998 il y a eu 79 lauréat du
challenge non plus de la moitié en 2017
est encore en activité
ça va apporter une certaine
reconnaissance des gens qu'on n'a pas
opté pour le travail réalisé l
entrepreneuriat ce quand même sur ses
pas rose il faut être un sacré
combattant
donc ça a permis d'accepter un peu de
félicitations une reconnaissance donc ça
c'était super et puis ça a clairement et
créer un réseau ouvert des portes qui
demandait à l'occasion de cette nouvelle
édition les sept lauréats gagneront une
aide de 7000 euros et 1500 euros pour
chaque finaliste une nouvelle catégorie
est créé pour les 20 ans la catégorie
start up
le jeune créateur d'entreprise ou le
moins jeunes gens 6 s'est ouverte à tous
les âges là la dame qui est à 60 ans et
qui a été licencié économique et qui
disait que je veux pas m'arrêter de
travailler je suis pas fini
elle va pouvoir créer son entreprise
rappelle que les conditions c'est avoir
créé sa boîte dans le deuxième semestre
2015 ou toute l'année 2016 et avoir été
demandeurs d'emploi au moment de la
création
les inscriptions pour le challenge 2017
se font en ligne sur le site www.cc de
7,4 point fr elles sont ouvertes
jusqu'au 31 août
[Musique]